[Music]
coming in december of this year
the third and most likely final part of
the spidey trilogy spider-man no way
home will finally hit theaters
the date mentioned so far is december
17th however
as we all know too well this can be
subject to change at any time
so far there are a lot of rumors about
no way home in this video we have taken
a closer look at which ones are
confirmed or denied
and what the plot might look like so
stay tuned
here comes our preview of spider-man no
way home
if you haven't seen the second part far
from home yet you should skip the coming
part as it contains spoilers
you've been warned what happened in
spider-man far from home
let's refresh your memory a little bit
peter and his high school buddies are on
a class trip when the world is suddenly
threatened by
elemental monsters yet it appears he
doesn't have to fight them
alone with quentin back a hero who wants
to take the burden on spidey's shoulders
and take on the task of saving the world
seems to enter the scene
his superhero alias mysterio however he
turns out to be an imposter who faked
everything with historic technology
barf in order to be held as a hero and
make big money
this technology creates holograms with
drones which are so real that it is
impossible to distinguish the reel from
the fake
there's a final battle between
spider-man and mysterio and london in
which mysterio is shot by his own drones
the world is once again saved but things
come
thick and fast for spidey in the mid
credits scene the publisher of the daily
bugle j
jonah jameson accuses the hero of being
responsible for the attacks of the
elementals and reveals his true
identity meaning that peter is now on
the run
jonah james was played by jk simmons by
the way why is that important you ask
well he already played the same role in
the spiderman trilogy starring toby
maguire
but we will get to that later the cast
of spider-man no way home is probably
one of the most hotly debated topics of
the past year when it comes to the mcu
and the movie before we take a closer
look at the rumors here are the actors
that we
absolutely know will play a role
needless to say
spider-man will once again be played by
tom holland who has long been the most
popular spider-man in a live action film
and one can hardly imagine a movie
without him
alas his contract expires after this
film but nevertheless
we will likely see him again in doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
naturally fans hope that his contract
will be extended one more time and many
assume that it will
whether this is the case is something
that only disney and sony know though
standing by his side will again be the
beautiful mj and his nerdy friend ned
leeds
they will also continue to be portrayed
by zendaya marie's derma coleman
and jacob batalon as is well known of
course ant-may can't be missing from
this trio
we look forward to seeing marissa to me
in this role again also back from high
school or netsuite heard betty brandt
and flash thompson who mostly uses high
school to trample on peter especially
when it comes to the multiverse which
will almost certainly play a big part
flash should play an interesting role
but we will talk more about that
later as you might expect these casts
also remain the same
with betty continuing to be played by
angry rice and thompson by
tony revolori if you look at the cast
overview you can't avoid reading the
name
benedict cumberbatch therefore we can
look forward to seeing what kind of
significance the role of doctor strange
will have in spidey's third film
it is just logical that he will be
featured since tom han is also supposed
to make an appearance in the multiverse
of madness
and when it comes to multiverses then
who should be appearing
if not the strange in addition daredevil
actor charlie cox has been spotted on
this set
for a long time rumors have been
circulating that the devil of hell's
kitchen would find a place in the mcu
the fact that the character may not be
already cast but that the already
existing character from the netflix
series will be integrated into the
spider verse
would certainly be a great surprise for
all fans unfortunately this has not yet
been officially confirmed
but the odds are good particularly
because the two-year non-use agreement
for the character which was imposed by
netflix has come to an end
it is conceivable that as a lawyer matt
murdock will first take on the case of
the disgraced peter parker
one thing has already been confirmed and
is fueling the rumors about the
multiverse
alfred molina will again slip into the
role of otto octavius aka
doctor octopus and this is 17 years
after spider-man 2.
in addition jaime fox will again embody
max dillon aka electro
the latter was the villain in the
amazing spider-man 2 rise of electro in
which andrew garfield
played the role of the friendly spider
the return of these two villains opens
the door to the multiverse wide open and
naturally creates room for heaps of
speculation
so fans hope to see not only these two
guys but that the sinister 6 will
finally find their way into a spider-man
movie
for this to happen however mysterio
would have to have survived or possibly
come from another earth
dog and electro will definitely not be
the same as in the other movies
that much has already been confirmed to
us perhaps not a villain but in any case
certainly a most hated character is of
course
also chief editor jay jonah jameson
after making his first appearance in
this spidey trilogy in the mid credits
scene
he is now said to have a larger role in
no way home
understandably so considering we can
surely already imagine how he will drag
peter's name through the mud
as mentioned in the beginning of the
video he will be played by jk
simmons as in the maguire spidey trilogy
the return of the two villains from
previous movies naturally sparked the
rumors surrounding toby maguire
and andrew garfield the movies featuring
the former spider-man actors didn't
actually play in the mcu
however with the rise of the multiverse
a comeback doesn't seem out of the
question so far
up to now all inquiries about it have
been denied by marvel and body actors
but as we know they have been told to
shut up by the film studios anyway
the animated film spider-man into the
spider-verse in 2018 has
already demonstrated that having more
spideys in one film is not a bad idea
and after all it was also honored with
an oscar so we believe we speak for all
fans when we say
this would be a dream come true and by
the way
it doesn't seem to be ruled out yet that
miles morales will make his appearance
in a live-action movie as the 4th
spider-man
after all he is the main character from
into the spider-verse
and as we know from a deleted scene from
homecoming he already exists in the mcu
everyone agrees on one rumor though in
case maguire and garfield should come
back
we also hope for kirsten dunst is mary
jane watson and emma stone to play gwen
stacy again
beforehand it's always difficult to talk
about the plot without question fan
fiction or personal imagination will
also play a role in the following part
what is clear is that the multiverse is
about to collapse
hence spidey suddenly has to face all
sorts of villains and people from the
other spider-man universes
the point in time was already spoiled by
alfred molina in an interview
the role of doctor octopus is to be
taken up again in spider-man no way home
precisely at the point when he drowned
in spider-man 2.
yet it's not just the bad guys who will
make things difficult for spidey
now that his true identity has been
revealed he'll either be on the run most
of the time or he will need to find
himself a very good lawyer
good thing we have matt murdock back
this is also where you could bring in
the lawyer jennifer walters
her alter ego is probably better known
to you as she-hulk
regarding the villains there is one
scenario we can imagine
best namely that the sinister six end of
the room
electro and doghog are already confirmed
as two out of the four
after all although the vulture has been
in prison since homecoming
it shouldn't be too difficult to break
out no mysterio the sandman
and craven the hunter would still be
missing from the original six
however it's more likely that these will
be replaced by scorpion
reno and the hobgoblin scorpion as we've
already seen is in prison with vulture
and thus he's already in the mcu reno
also already made an appearance and
let's call it the garfield verse
so the only one missing is hobgoblin
some of you may already know him from
the comics but peter's friends ned leeds
turns into him in a comic series
however it would be conceivable that an
evil equivalent of him comes from an
alternate universe to complicate
spider-man's life with the other five
villains
however as mentioned earlier he may not
have to fight them alone
as maguire and garfield have already
collected their experience fighting
against some of the sinister six
in addition they're also dr strange and
daredevil for us
it's still a matter of patience and we
hope that we can really see the film on
december 17th
and hopefully in theaters as in the
first two parts john watts will be
directing the movie
and the script has been taken care of by
chris mckenna and eric summers
besides the script of the first two
films both are working on ant-man and
the wasp
for the shooting some high schools had
to be temporarily closed once again
filming also took place in new york's
greenwich village neighborhood where
doctor strange sanctum is located since
the contract between sony and marvel
expired in 2019
it was initially not certain how things
would continue
sony was willing to extend the contract
but marvel wanted an equal split of
profits to share production costs
luckily the parties were able to come to
an agreement in september 2019.
as a result marvel studios will get
their merchandise rights and 25
of the revenue but will have to bear
quarter of the production cost
so that was our preview of spider-man no
way home
hopefully we were able to give you a
good insight and increase your
excitement for december
what do you think is it realistic to see
of three spideys in one single movie or
do you have a different theory regarding
the villains
let us know in the comment section and
if you liked the video feel free to give
it a thumbs up
see you next time
[Music]
you